Speaker 1: Hey, there is this new theme.
There's this new talking point that has surfaced
when public figures are asked about their
vaccination status, where they say, that's
my hip, that's my hip, or that's hip hop.
We're going to talk about the absurdity of
this.
I've actually mentioned this three or four
times over the last two months when it would
sort of rear its ugly head, but very ignorant
head and explain hip hop has nothing to do
with journalists talking to public figures.
It just doesn't add you look up the law, look
at what hip is.
But it's now becoming a very common refrain
for people who just don't want to answer whether
they've been vaccinated.
So let's look at some examples.
Here is radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Green.
She has done anti vax stuff.
She has done compare things to the Holocaust
stuff, which she then apologized for, but
then did it again.
This is one of the most radical, ignorant,
unhinged members of Congress.
She invoked her hip rights.
I know, I know she was asked, are you vaccinated
by a reporter and she said, that's a violation
of my hip.
OK, take a look.
Two questions.
Have you
Speaker 2: gotten vaccinated and do you disagree
with that Republican
Speaker 3: women?
Well, your your first question is a violation
of my rights.
You see, whatever rights, we don't have to
reveal our medical records, and that also
involves our vaccine records.
Speaker 1: So she clearly doesn't understand
or is pretending not to understand what HEPA
is.
Here's another example.
Dallas Cowboys quarterback Dak Prescott asked,
are you vaccinated?
And he said that that's hipper.
Hold on.
Is being asked that hipper or is answering
it?
What does it mean that's hipper?
It makes no sense.
But let's take a look at the video.
Speaker 2: You got the vaccine?
I don't necessarily think that's exactly important,
Clarence.
I think that's helpful.
But I understand where Zeke comes from.
I understand everybody's opinion, and I think
everybody
Speaker 1: has that right, my hip, hip, this
hip that I would even go further.
Guys, I think being asked about vaccination
violates the Nuremberg codes.
It violates the Geneva Convention.
It violates everything penal code.
I mean, there's there's throw throw any misused
legal term out.
It violates all of it.
And the funniest little detail is 90 percent
of the time they're misspelling Hepi.
If you look through our YouTube channel comments,
which I don't encourage you to do on it, on
an empty stomach if you're planning to eat
soon, because it's going to really spoil your
appetite 90 percent of the time that people
talking about Hypatia in the context of being
asked about vaccinations spell it like hippo,
but with an A..
It's HEPA HIPAA.
It stands for Health Insurance Portability
and Accountability Act.
Now, to be really crystal clear, HEPA relates
only to the storage and the transmission of
your medical records by medical providers
and by insurance companies.
When you ask someone about their covid vaccine
status, it's not it's not even to say to say
it's a hip violation.
It has nothing to do with hip hop.
And especially when a journalist asks a public
figure, are you vaccinated?
It has nothing to do with hip hip.
It was signed into law by Bill Clinton in
1996.
What was happening in 96, medical records
were in the process of being computerized
and what HEPA did.
HEPA doesn't block anyone from asking questions
about health status.
What it does is prohibit certain health care
entities from revealing your health information.
That's all it does and it shouldn't surprise
us in a sense.
So I tweeted over the weekend initially I
tweeted over the weekend the stupidity of
claiming Hipp of violations when journalists
ask public figures about their vaccination
status is actually even taking me by surprise.
But then I thought about it a little more
and I realized what I tweeted out the next
day.
It's not surprising that the same people who
think Twitter is violating their First Amendment
rights think that a journalist is violating
PIPA.
Don't let them get away with this.
And I think there's there's basically two
things that should be done when these people
try to assert their hippo rights, which is
it's crazy.
It's sort of like I'm asserting I'm asserting
the laws of gravity really well.
What does it mean to assert them?
You're bound by them regardless.
It just makes no sense.
I think that there's two things that should
be said.
One is what is hippo?
What explain what Hippo does and how it relates
to the question you were asked.
It has to be done.
And it's going to be like when people say
that's socialism and we say, what is socialism
anyway?
They don't know, OK, ask what is hip hop?
But then more importantly, once you've established
that they don't even know, go further and
say, hey, regardless of whether this is Hip-Hop,
why is it you don't want to reveal your vaccination
status?
Because that I'm not hearing that question
being asked.
And that's really the key question.
That's not a trivial thing.
Whether or not someone can be forced to reveal
their vaccination status or whether a question
violates mean none of it makes any sense at
a certain point when it's a public figure.
The next question should be, OK, listen, let's
not debate hip hop.
What I want to know is why are you so interested
in keeping secret your vaccination status?
Is it because you're worried that the people
that have heard you do the anti back stuff
and love you for it and donate to you for
it are all of a sudden going to abandon you
if they realize actually you've been vaccinated?
Is it because you've not been vaccinated and
you want to hide that?
My instinct is, for the most part, the people
who don't want to acknowledge their vaccination
status publicly are right wingers who have
toyed with antibiotics.
So my instinct is they've probably mostly
been vaccinated and think it would be damn.
To the brand or would appear hypocritical
to admit that they've received the vaccination.
That's my instinct.
I'd love to hear from
you about it.